>>Female Presenter: As Frank will discuss
in a few moments, we are no longer passive
consumers of mass media or spectators. Now,
thanks to Google+, we hope, Twitter, and YouTube,
we are media. Storytelling is no longer linear
and we are frequently asked to participate.
This new narrative is still nascent, but continues
to gain momentum. "The Art of Immersion" examines
the blurred lines between author and audience,
story and game, entertainment and marketing,
and fiction and reality--what we call "deep
media." Just so you guys know this might run
a couple of times through this talk.
It's actually our freight elevator. So, if
you hear that just sort of go with it. Following
Frank's talk of "The Art of Immersion," he'll
be joined by some transmedia pioneers for
a conversation about the changing nature of
storytelling, collaborative production, and
how these immersive experiences actually come
to fruition. So please join me in welcoming
Frank.
[applause]
>>Frank: Thank you. OK. Hi. So, I'm gonna
talk a little bit about grammar today, but
don't worry. It doesn't have anything to do
with linguistics. I'm going to talk about
the grammar of storytelling--how it's evolving,
why it's evolving, and why that matters to
us.
So, as Janine pointed out, I wrote this book
about how the internet was changing storytelling
essentially. And the thing about storytelling
is that it's always been mediated by technology,
by whatever technology is at hand. And as
I was working on the book, I realized early
on that every medium has its own grammar.
Cinema, for example. We take for granted the
grammar of cinema because we're used to watching
movies. People have been watching movies now
for a hundred years or more. But all of the
parts of that grammar, cross-cuts, fades,
point of view shots, even a close-up, they
all had to be invented.
They weren't there at the beginning. And so
the motion picture camera was invented around
1890. And for a long time, for a number of
years, the typical shot was what's called
the proscenium arch shot, which is to say
as if the camera were set in amid the audience,
looking up at the action taking place on stage.
All of these other shots and the cutting and
so forth, all that happened gradually over
a period of years. It wasn't really consolidated
until about 1915. And in fact, it was 1910
before they even came up with the idea of
movie stars. So, what essentially happened
was we had a 20-year period from the invention
of the camera to the idea of putting stars
in front of it.
And another five years after that, before
the grammar really coalesced. And 12 more,
of course, 'till we got sound. So, as it happens,
it's been about 20 years now since the birth
of the web. And we're still figuring that
out, too. What I realized when I was working
on the book was that every new medium seems
to take about 20 or 30 years for people to
figure out what to do with it.
And in the meantime, we have I've come to
call the "horseless carriage" phase. Transitional,
obviously, when we don't really understand
the possibilities of the new technology. As
with the proscenium arch shot, we just continue
doing what we've done in the past.
But it's not just a question of seeing the
new in terms of the old. It's also defining
the new in terms of what it's lacking rather
than what it can become. So, I think that's
what's happened with the internet. A lot of
internet critics are basically saying, "Where's
the horse?"
"Social media devalues friendship. Where is
the horse?" “Google makes me stupid. Where's
the horse?" "Bloggers don't have proper journalism
credentials. Where is the horse?" Well, the
horse is gone and it's not coming back. So,
what do we have instead?
We have essentially a medium that consists
of all media that is video, audio, print,
any combination of the above. And that can
be used in a way that's inherently non-linear,
that is also inherently participatory. It
encourages people to jump in to act. As a
result, it's often game-like.
It has the capability of being immersive.
And it blurs boundaries relentlessly. The
boundary between author and audience, between
fiction and reality, between story and game,
between entertainment and marketing. In the
process of all this, it really changes the
way we think.
For example, I'm gonna talk for a moment about
nonlinearity and what that does. So, nonlinear
storytelling is not new, of course. In the
20th Century, it was pretty much the province
of the avant garde. You had James Joyce. You
had Jorge Luis Borges. You had Akira Kurosawa,
Jean Luc Godard.
Godard’s, in a debate at Cannes in the mid-'60s,
was famously asked if he didn't think a story
should have a beginning, a middle, and an
end, to which he replies, "Certainly, but
not necessarily in that order." This kind
of nonlinear storytelling was self-conscious.
It was intellectual and arty.
It was essentially calling attention to the
illusion that is narrative, which is kind
of a no-no in certainly classical, Hollywood
cinema and fiction in general. But then something
strange started to happen. By the mid-'90s,
nonlinearity had been absorbed by the culture
to the point that Quentin Tarantino could
release "Pulp Fiction", a movie that to most
video executives at the time was utterly unwatchable.
And to a new generation of viewers, it was
an entirely natural way to tell a story. Nonlinearity
was going mainstream. Within a few years,
you had Christopher Nolan's "Memento." You
had David Lynch making "Mulholland Drive."
I talked to Lynch when I was working on the
book because I wanted to ask him about this
whole question of nonlinearity, where it's
coming from, why it's become popular.
And what he said really suggested to me "television."
And when you think about it, television is
an extremely nonlinear experience. We're trained
not to think of it this way. We're trained
to think of discrete elements. We watch the
TV show, there's a break, we watch the news,
we watch some ads, we go back to the show.
But in fact, this is an extremely disjointed
and nonlinear experience. And then of course,
you have the web coming in, a technology,
a medium, that's essentially based on, because
of hyperlinks, it's essentially based on the
whole idea of nonlinearity.
In 2005, Alissa Quart, a film critic writing
in film comment, coined the term "hyperlink
cinema." And a few months after that, Roger
Ebert in a review of "Syriana" wrote, used
the same term. And he wanted to give credit
to Alissa Quart, but unfortunately as he pointed
out, irony of ironies, "I've lost the link."
[laughter]
So, there's one more thing about the horse's
carriage analogy. Not only does it lack a
horse, but it's still a carriage. People are
trying to construct at this point, with the
internet, the equivalent of a purpose-built
motor car. That's kind of where we are with
storytelling right now.
We know the parameters. We know that it encourages
nonlinearity. It has to be participatory in
some way. All of these things. But that doesn't
tell us how to use these things. It doesn't
tell you the grammar. We still have to create
that. And this book that I've written it's
really a meta-narrative about the search for
this new grammar.
For me, it's then really an extraordinary
journey. And it began with three stories that
I did for Wired over a period of a couple
of years before I actually started the book
and before I had even the idea for the book.
The first one was a piece on 3D, for which
I interviewed James Cameron in the fall of
2006.
At that point "Avatar" had not yet been green
lit. He had it in development. He had it in
development for some time. He was in Montreal
on a sound stage where they were making "Journey
to the Center of the Earth" in 3D, which was
the first feature film to use the 3D camera
system that he and Vince Pace had invented.
So, I went up there and it turned out he had
a lot of free time, which was great. And so,
we talked about "Avatar” a fair amount.
And in particular, he talked about that kind
of science fiction story as one that was ideal
for creating a "fractal-like complexity,"
as he put it.
So, the casual viewer could just see the movie,
but for the real fan, he could jump in another
order of magnitude and the pattern would still
hold up. Really, you could have stories of
almost infinite levels of depth, immersive
entertainment. Just like Star Wars has become.
Of course, Star Wars was the movie that inspired
Cameron to become a director in the first
place. About a year after that, I did a story
on "Year Zero," the alternate reality game.
It was really a piece on the whole idea of
alternate reality games and we picked that
as the one to focus on.
It was an incredibly immersive experience
based on the Nine Inch Nails album called
Year Zero. Trent Reznor had made this album
and he had a problem. He essentially created
a concept album, but at a time when nobody
buys albums anymore and certainly they don't
buy albums that come with liner notes and
the like.
So, his problem was what are you supposed
to do? How do you even convey to people that
this is a concept album, much less what the
concept is? And in his case, it was a completely
fascinating story about America as a theocratic
police state 15 years in the future.
So, he engaged Susan Bonds, who's the CEO
of 42 Entertainment, who is here by the way.
She's going to join us in a few minutes. And
Alex Lieu, who works with her. And the result
was a game that played out over a period of
many months and to about two and a half million
people.
Alternate reality games like this really do
blur the line. They blur the line between
story and game. You have, essentially, a series
of riddles and puzzles and treasure hunts,
that unlike a story, which the players then
tell to each other online. So in a sense,
they become the owners of it.
And at the same time, they blur the line between
fiction and reality. You have real events
taking place in a fictional world, except
that it can't be fictional because we're in
it. And it's not on-screen or on stage. It's
happening all around us. Finally, it blurs
the line between marketing and entertainment.
It's fun, but it also builds a lot of excitement
about whatever it is that it's connected to,
whether it's Year Zero or subsequently, 42
did one for The Dark Knight. And in fact,
one of the first alternate reality games was
commissioned by Microsoft for the release
of Halo 2.
That was called "I Love Bees." And the person
who did that, Chris DiCesare is also gonna
join us in a few minutes. He was at Microsoft
Games Studio at the time and he told me when
I was interviewing him for the book that he
thought he might get fired over this.
He was spending a million dollars in an unproven
medium for a marketing effort that he couldn't
even admit existed. And yet, its success was
supposed to be measured in the amount of publicity
it drew. So, actually he didn't get fired,
but he did end up at Google some time later.
[audience chuckles]
So, we'll hear from him. And finally, I did
a story about a year after that about Hollywood
getting into the whole idea of web video.
This was as a result of the writer's strike
largely. Film and television writers obviously
doing the strike, they couldn't write for
film or television, but they could write for
the web.
So, a lot of them did. And I came across a
lot of people, or several people, who had
started off as TV writers and they'd gone
into video games, working for Activision,
working for electronic arts, which of course
is a huge studio in Playa Vista. And they
were wondering how you could really combine
the two.
That's what their motivation was in doing
this. And at the same time, there was another
question, which was, how do you pay for these
things? They didn't have a big enough audience
really to be supported by conventional commercials.
And the infrastructure for that wasn't even
in place at that point anyway.
So, what happened was you had a lot of product
placement. You had what has come to be known
as "branded entertainment," where brands and
storytellers got together and did something.
So we have a couple of people here also who
are experts in that in one form or another.
Paul Woolmington from Naked Communications,
a branding agency that's based in London,
has a big office here and many other places
in the world. And Ted Hope, who's one of the
leading indie producers in the US, indie film
producers. He's produced such films as "21
Grams," "The Laramie Project," "American Splendor,"
and the list goes on.
So, the final question I want to get back
to is, why does all this matter? Why is storytelling
so important? Why is it so basic to us? I
think it's because stories put information
in a framework. They're essentially processing
mechanisms. They create a signal within the
noise.
And that's how we process information. We
can--. We're capable of following instructions.
We can use a recipe. We can go through a checklist.
We can follow a set of instructions, but we're
not really that good at it because we're not
particularly methodical creatures.
Instruction sets are essentially lists, and
lists are very hard to learn. Stories are
easy to learn because they're easy to grab
on to. They're a way to store memories, which
is why I think that it's fair to say that
stories are to humans as algorithms are to
machines.
So, that's where we stand. It's 2011. We think
we live on internet time, but that's really
just things coming at us. It doesn't have
anything to do with our ability to process
it. And the truth is we're still groping towards
something new. It's really an essential and
completely exciting phase, I think.
But we might as well be trying to make movies
in 1911. You know, people were feeling pretty
good about it back then, too. Nickelodeon
is so 1908. It figured out movie stars. They'd
mastered the jump cut and the fade. But spoken
dialogue was still years away and color, it
was hard to even imagine what color would
look like.
So, who's going to figure this one out? Who's
going to take the next step; construct a new
grammar of storytelling for us now? When we
know that, I think we'll know how this meta-story
is going to end. Thank you.
[applause]
[freight elevator sounds] [Frank Rose chuckles]
>>Paul Woolmington: So, as we smoothly transition
into this next part of the [chuckles]--. I'm
Paul Woolmington of Naked Communications.
And Frank has eloquently introduced all of
us, so I'm not gonna do all those boring introductions.
[freight elevator sounds in background]
I feel like a giant lorry's about to crash
through the--. Anyway, Janine asked if I would
very informally moderate and all assist the
conversation. And I think the rule number
one is to really just keep out of the way
and let the conversation flow. So, I just
wanted to maybe kick off.
And we'll try and leave a little time for
obviously audience participation and I'm sure
you've got some questions which might elaborate
on Frank's early point. So, I just wanted
to kick off with Susan. Susan, it occurred
to me that you have been doing this, trying
to figure this out for longer than most from
what Frank was saying.
Any observations from you where we stand today?
Because we were just, even the discourse we
had a little earlier, you were saying like,
Twitter didn't exist but a few years ago and
you were doing some of these amazing transmedia,
whatever you wanna call it, narratives way
before that.
But just any observations from when you first
started producing amazing nonlinear stories
to where it stands today?
>>Susan Bonds: Well, absolutely. So, I think
it is really this kind of strange juxtaposition
of the fact that storytelling is as old as
anything that we can remember. And it's at
a central part of our life and it's something
that people don't have to teach us.
We all know how to tell a story. I'm sure
you guys can tell a good story here. So, it's
like something that's really part of who we
are and combining that with the fact that
not only is technology moving at a rapid pace,
but also the way we interact as a society,
the way we interact in our social groups,
the way we interact with each other, the fact
that we're now all connected, which is something
I don't have to explain to this room.
So, I think that we tried to approach it from
the viewpoint of wherever we are, it's an
opportunity. It's an opportunity to tell a
story that connects people. And the fact that
we are so connected actually is an opportunity
in itself. The one thing that was true ten
years ago, and is true today, is that the
web gives you instant feedback.
So, as a creative storyteller, you have to
deal with that. And when you let people into
your world and into your story, you then have
to deal with their expectations. So, I think
overall, if you look over the past decade,
people's expectations have grown significantly.
[audience member's phone alarm beeps]
And now, what used to be surprising and novel
is expected. And if you don't do that, then
bad mark on you. So, it's interesting to see
how things have evolved and I don't know if
you guys probably felt like I did when you
saw the social network. It's like, that was
2004? [laughs lightly]
Oh, my God. It's like the world has changed
so fast and again, what happens here at Google
it's like keeping up with it is in one sense
it's challenging, but in the other sense it's
natural. This is a natural evolution. That's
why anybody can do it. It's because it's just
the way things are going.
>>Paul Woolmington: Chris, do you?
>>Chris Di Cesare: The thing that I think
is interesting is just as time has gone on,
how brands have learned how they have to accept
the consumer participation dialogue in the
process.
And I worked a lot on YouTube. One of the
stories that I remember--and this is a little
different than storytelling but it goes back
to that--I remember that whole Diet Coke Mentos
spots, when those videos first appeared and
they, how the brands dealt with that so differently.
Like, Mentos just shipped boxes of Mentos
to the guys behind it, where Diet Coke was
like, "OK, we gotta stop this. We have this.
[Ted Hope and Paul Woolmington laugh] They're
fucking with our brand over here. We can't
have that." So, and I think brands now, they
have to figure out how to have them participate
in that process. It's just an evolution.
>>Paul Woolmington: It was an interesting
inflection point, wasn't it? That classic
people going white-knuckles in the Coke board
room. And Mentos on the opposite were like,
they were going, "Yay! We're the little guys."
>>Chris Di Cesare: Exactly.
>>Paul Woolmington: And the Coke guys going,
"Oh my God, what exploding Coke." I'm gonna
quote from Frank's book, a lovely little quote
that I actually used in presentation, I was
telling him. "In a command and control world,
we know who is telling the story, it's the
author.
But digital media and this new era has created
an authorship crisis. Once the audience is
free to step into the fiction and start directing
events, the entire edifice of the 20th Century
mass media begins to crumble." But I-I- Ted,
you've been deeply involved and obviously
working with writers and incredible directors
and actors.
I just wondered, what excites you about this
blurred line between audience and author?
Any comments? Any thoughts about how that
inflection point has changed your world, or
might?
>>Ted Hope: Quite a few. It's interesting,
I think, that the brands are actually far
more progressive than the artists or authors
are. In terms of what's attracted me to whether
it's transmedia, deep media, storytelling,
part of it is trying to confront the superabundance
of stories, of content that's out there.
Friends of mine who worked in the film festival
submission world clocked it at around, they
thought that around about 45 thousand titles
are generated a year.
>>Paul Woolmington: Wow.
>>Ted Hope: Forty-five thousand titles and
the US market currently is thought to be able
to consume about 600 theatrical titles a year,
of which 125 are studios. Which means that
the available market share for the world supply
is 1% a year of the world's supply.
And that's this year. Next year, there's still
another 44,400 films that weren't seen. So,
it's down to 0.55%. And then you look at how
fast the past is digitized on top of that.
You could live,you could say today, "I wanna
live in 1968," and do that more fully than
you could in 1968 and just see content from
that.
[Paul Woolmington laughs]
As a filmmaker and as an artist, how do I
get my films seen? And to think that the feature
film form, even quality storytelling, even
corporately-backed quality storytelling is
enough to get traction with the global audience
is foolish.
The one advantage I have to somebody like
Kurosawa, a far better storyteller than I,
is that I'm not dead.
>>Paul Woolmington: You've got one advantage.
>>Ted Hope: That's it. I can make my stories
penetrate deeper in many different ways, but
when I start talking to the directors and
writers that I work with and I say, "You know?
This bit of the script, I don't actually think
we should provide that plot point. I think
we should keep it a little open-ended here
and not try to spell this out so that later
we can have an opening to go back to."
They kinda look at me and, "who goes back
[Paul Woolmington laughs]
to do that?" "What are you talking about?"
"Well, maybe it's gonna be someone in the
audience, that goes --." And it just stops.
And it's so hard to try to start to get people
to start to look at like, how do we start
making these films be a two-way street where
there's a place that people can participate?
>>Paul Woolmington: Frank, I mean, I'd love
to bring you back in at this point on that;
the blurred line between author and audience.
I mean, at what point will there be an inflection
point on the demise of the mass media 'cause
obviously we've got a lot of Googlers here?
>>Frank Rose: Right. I think that if anything,
the people who are doing the kind of thing
that I'm talking about often err on the side
of abdicating the storytelling. And the people,
as you were saying, Ted, who are more used
to doing a much more traditional form of storytelling
take it the opposite way.
I think that the only reason that people become
interested in a story in the first place is
because it's a great story, whether it's Star
Wars, whether it's Avatar, whether it's Harry
Potter. The question, the trick really becomes
how do you balance that and how do you leave
out things that you were saying, Ted.
How do you leave openings for the audience
to come in? I had this conversation with Damon
Lindelof and Carlton Cuse when I was interviewing
them for the book. They were the show runners,
of course, of Lost. And what they said was
that they felt that the show gave the illusion
of interactivity, but in fact wasn't really.
But in a way that wasn't entirely true because
what happened with that story, I mean, number
one, that was an extremely controlled bit
of storytelling. It went on for six years.
It was an extremely selective release of information.
And it was so complicated that essentially
what happened was the audience had to get
together online just to figure out what the
story was.
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah.
>>Frank Rose: So, you had things like Lostpedia,
which was specifically founded by, started
by some guy who, in Anchorage, Alaska, who
had watched the entire first season in a couple
of nights before the second season started.
And then he watched the first show of the
second season and he had a complete WTF moment.
[laughter]
And so, he went online to find out what was
going on and he didn't find anything except
a few discussion threads. And so, he decided
to start a wiki on it. And he was familiar
enough with the Wikipedia software that he
had it up and running in about six hours.
And now it's in 19 or 20 languages. There
are thousands of articles. It's extraordinary.
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah. No, that's great.
Chris, I was gonna bring you in at this point
a bit more that having worked obviously at
Microsoft, having been a marketeer, having
I guess also participated in creating something
with Susan back along.
I was just wondering what do you think that
computer and video games, why that had such
a disruptive influence on the overall entertainment
industry? 'Cause obviously, we still talk
about Hollywood--and of course everyone knows
the statistic--
Hollywood gets the lion's share of the ink,
but gaming has long since passed it in terms
of gross revenues. And how is that obviously
changing the way we do things?
>>Chris Di Cesare: I think video games are
just the evolution of our time. I mean, first
and foremost it just puts you at the center
of the experience. So, being able to live
that role provides that degree of immersiveness
that I think everyone's striving towards.
I mean, I think that's touched on in the book.
Like, everyone wants go deeper, get closer
to the characters and so forth. And it's one
of these things where I think people in video
games admire the storytellers in Hollywood
and the Hollywood guys kinda go, "Oh, I wanna
be more, kinda closer to the game."
And they both battle it out to figure out
which way it's going. I think in gaming in
general, just as technology is advanced, you're
able to add. the characters have had more
dimension to them so that, like a category
unto itself, like a shooter, right? In the
past, all the shooters were the same, just
blow things up.
But now, you're able to tell more richer,
deeper stories. And I think that was the thing
like on Halo, the property I was involved
with. It was similar to Star Wars in a way
where they didn't think of themselves as creating
a game. They were thinking of creating a universe,
first and foremost, that people could play
in.
And I think now as technology has advanced,
you can see that get closer to the characters.
And you see it happen when a video game can
now sell, have bestselling books and so forth.
They wanna get closer to it.
>>Paul Woolmington: Susan, just to pick up
on that because obviously a lot the activities
you've created have a lot of play. I mean,
clearly there's players inherent in everything
that you're doing, but how do,
do you codify this? Do you think about these
spurs, these behavioral spurs? Or, is it sort
of? Tell us a little bit about the creative
process that you go through. I mean, are there
any examples you can give, or whether you
have methodologies that you use at these different
inflection points?
>>Susan Bonds: Well, so just to echo what
Chris is saying, I think when you watch a
story and you see the knight save the village
or get the girl, it's like, "Well, I wanna
be that person. I wanna be the hero of the
story."
I mean, we all remember The Matrix when Neo
got the package and he ripped it open and
there's a phone and it says, "Follow the white
rabbit." And you're like, "I wanna do that."
And that was one of our goals was just to
essentially create that moment, that Matrix
moment, where the phone rings, you're given
instructions and then you're off.
You have no idea where you're going. So, as
part of the Year Zero project that Frank was
mentioning, we had created a world that was
obviously being sent back in pieces, 15 years
from the future. And the players were deciphering
it and putting it together. What's the vision
of this world?
In a way, it was like narrative archeology.
We're getting these shards, these little bits
of glimpses of digital media that are reflective
of the society of the day. Well, what were
those people like? What are the issues they're
dealing with? And as part of that, we wanted
to transfer that somehow a sense of urgency
to today.
So, one of the things that we did is that
we introduced the idea that in the future,
you were gonna lose things that were very
basic to you. And that one of the ways that
people were fighting back was through art.
And one of the messages was the fact that
you have a voice and you don't have to necessarily
agree with me, but you just need to speak
up.
And this was something that people could hold
on to that had relevance for them. So, I think
that in the video game genre, you can be the
hero, but if you can somehow make it relevant
to the point where you now see the world through
the game layer, or the alternate reality or
whatever it is that you put over it, then
you have a win because you're really giving
people a different point of reference which
they have a very personal connection to.
It's like, "Well, I'm the hero of this story
and it's making me think about this." And
so, I think that's a good example of how if
you create that personal moment, I do agree
that there has to be a balance between a story
that you're, I would say this, a world that
you're creating that's fully realized in detail
that people can play.
And then you give them a path through that
or give them the tools to really add value
to the world.
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah, Ted?
>>Ted Hope: It's curious. The films that I've
done are independent films, which probably
the best way to describe it is really in personal
tales, real life, raw emotion. And as I've
wanted to explore a different way of telling
stories, I've moved more into some genre topics
of superheroes and horror, mostly because
it's in sci-fi.
It allows you more free reign, but I've continued
to try to strive to try to figure out how
you can expand beyond a feature film narrative
within a more traditional story. And a lot
of the films that I've made have had unsympathetic
characters at their center, that I've always
been drawn to how films create empathy, how
you can start to understand somebody who you
normally wouldn't ever want to be in contact
with in other situations.
And as I start to push the writers and directors
that I work with to really try to consider
a multi-platform mode of storytelling, we
often will say, "OK, do these supporting characters.
Can we do a Rosencrantz and Guildenstern device
and focus a little bit on a supporting character?"
We had a film this year that won Best Director
at the Sundance Film Festival called "Martha
Marcy May Marlene." And it's a story of a
young woman who had been abducted into a cult.
And as the movie opens, she escapes and reunites
with her sister who she was estranged from,
but her mind's been blown and she's suspecting
the cult's coming to get her.
And well, you'll have to go see the movie
when it comes out this fall.
[laughter]
But before we ever did that, I kept pushing
the filmmakers to try to write five short
pieces about the different members of the
cult. I got one done. But we made a short
film.
And kinda it's curious when you think of the
different levels of audiences. Some audiences
want to drill down really deep and really
engage. For me, as a producer, my audiences
frequently start with the financiers. And
then the actors. And then the distributors.
How do I reach them?
And so, this short was made for the audience
of the film festivals in some ways. We made
this short film with some of the characters
we cast in the feature film in the same story
world that we later made the feature in. And
it went to Sundance. It went to the New York
Film Festival.
It won a prize in Cannes. And that's exactly
the path that the feature now is going because
it introduced, it was the discovery mechanism
for that audience of how they came to discover
this filmmaker and this story. And I think
that trying to come up with ways that we do
it in a non-genre context where it isn't the
glimpse of a futuristic world, or the threat,
or things that run on more gaming principles.
How do we encourage engagement across platform
without necessarily using game mechanics is
another place where there's gonna be a lot
of growth and a lot of soul searching in some
ways of trying to figure out. So, if you can
figure that part out, Susan.
[laughter]
>>Paul Woolmington: Susan?
>>Susan Bonds: Wow. So, I think of, I understand
what you're saying about telling personal
stories and certainly about unsympathetic
characters, but we've always tried to, and
this isn't a game theory, this is a storytelling
principle, it's like, "We'll figure out something
that resonates with everyone."
For example, when I was working with Chris
and we were talking about Halo, it was more
than just--. Well, first of all they had built
this fully-realized world. So if it's how
to make it personal to us. And the idea came
up about telling a War of the Worlds story
because we've all thought of that moment of
what if something unexpected happens?
What do you do? How do you handle it? Obviously,
that was the whole beauty of War of the Worlds
is it felt like it was really happening. So,
how do we take that and modernize it? And--
>>Ted Hope: But I would actually say that
the whole beauty, and I think this is something
that Frank hits in his book, is actually that
it was a trick, which made it a story that
we could pass on. So, my son knows of War
of the Worlds as a prank. And that's so exciting
to him that somebody could've pranked the
nation.
>>Susan Bonds: Pranked the nation.
[laughter]
I think Google could prank the nation. I'm
waiting for that.
[laughter]
>>Chris Di Cesare: But the thing is, I think,
like a lot of it is the--. So, in the ARGs
or in the War of the Worlds premise as a whole,
what's interesting is that you have this umbrella
story, but the real thing that drives it is
not the story itself I find, but the stories
from the participants and their engagement,
their involvement in the actual process.
Like, for the I Love Bees thing, people, they
didn't talk about like what was the story
that they talked about like War of the Worlds.
It was more like, "Well, there's this guy
who's battling a hurricane in order to get
to a pay phone in order to pick up the phone
'cause the story had to go on."
These human stories became what drove it because
it was a unique way of telling stories.
>>Paul Woolmington: Frank, any thoughts on
that?
>>Frank Rose: I think that, I mean, one of
the things I was really fascinated by when
I was working on the book was I did a series
of interviews with Howard Roffman, who's in
charge of the Star Wars Expanded Universe
at Lucas Film.
And essentially, although we didn't exactly
talk about it in these terms, what we got
into was a whole idea of story worlds. I mean,
that's a phrase that's become a bit more popularized
now. But what he was saying was that George
Lucas, when he was first making the films,
when he started making the films, he created
this, what Lucas called an "immaculate reality."
He realized every detail. And he didn't do
that, Howard pointed out, because he thought
you could spin stories off of it, spin more
stories off of it. He did it because that's
what you have to do in order to make something
seem real when the whole thing is made-up,
when there is no Planet Tatooine, there are
no moisture farmers--
>>Susan Bonds: What?
[laughter]
>>Frank Rose: I'm sorry.
We'll talk later. But ultimately what happened
was that because the world that he created
was so incredibly rich in detail, it meant
that there were all of these sort of handholds
that you could grab onto and use to spin more
stories off of.
I was just fascinated by that. I always thought
that was a great--.
>>Paul Woolmington: Frank and I played this
game a little while ago, a month or so ago,
and I just wanted to bring Ted in on this
one. OK. In a storytelling duel, who in your
opinion would win, Dickens, Lucas, Spielberg,
or J.J. Abrams?
[Ted laughs]
Or you can add who you think could--.
>>Ted Hope: It's, I think in the same sort
of way, the folks who make the biggest myths,
whether it's the Grimm Brothers, Greek mythology,
the Bible, any of those things that allow
people to take for themselves and spin again,
works really well.
So, the folks that were a little less hung
up on their own authorship, I think, actually
probably wins because they generate more stories,
whether they're the pen or not would be my
argument. So, maybe not those folks at all.
Folks who had maybe a slight lesser output
themselves, but allowed other people to take
those tales and run with it.
And I think it's, part of the problem is that
we still hold up these big storytelling Gods
and link their name. And yet, in terms of
the filmmakers, for the most part, you could
argue that what Lucas later,
ultimately what Lucas has created, extends
well beyond the features in a much stronger
way. But the dominance of the feature film
form as a prime financial vehicle, I think,
has limited people's ability to launch new
characters, to not launch new worlds.
And as we start to, as filmmakers loosen up
and can see themselves more as a brand that
can speak in different formats across different
genres in different time lengths. They can
put out all of these little pieces. And to
me, the beauty of a story that you start today,
but I don't actually plan to finish or actually
make my main component of it for 15 years
from now, that to me is a great challenge
and a great glory.
That's the duel that I'd love to challenge
those great masters to 'cause they were stuck
in a dominant form. And I think that right
now, we're at the point where that's really
breaking down. In terms of film, the dominance
of the feature film, I think, has ended.
We haven't seen the results of it, but we're
right there. That's what has occurred over
the last couple years.
>>Paul Woolmington: An observation to pick
up on what you were saying is, inherent in
what you were saying, is we have this muscle
memory that's built into all of ourselves.
And we have this sense of control. Part of
that is this sense of ownership and/or control.
But how do we release this muscle memory?
Is it just gonna happen through the participation
of audiences? Through the loosening of social
media 'cause people are gonna change the way
their behavior acts? Is it gonna happen from
ground up, so to speak?
I mean, is that what we're seeing? I mean,
Susan, what are your thoughts on the muscle
memory issue 'cause you've probably come up
against it many times,how to break through.
>>Susan Bonds: Definitely. I mean, I love
movies. I'll just have to tell you that. I
mean, I think when we were growing up, it's
like we all have had that experience where
we lost ourself in a world.
And I think one of the things that all the
people certainly on that list have is this.
We've all left their media daydreaming in
those worlds because they were so fully realized.
We could actually put ourselves in it. So,
I actually think, and someone has said this
before, that I think it's the meeting in the
middle.
We still need great storytellers and I think
YouTube has probably proven without a shadow
of a doubt that we're not all great storytellers.
[laughter]
Can I say that authoritatively?
>>Chris Di Cesare: You can say that.
>>Susan Bonds: OK.
>>Chris Di Cesare: There's a few.
>>Susan Bonds: So, we need this creative force
coming and bringing these fully realized worlds
to us. But I also agree adamantly with Ted,
which is, if these creative forces can loosen
up a little bit, there's ways to let people
into your world that really can add value.
And so, I think Ted mentioned that War of
the Worlds told over pay phones was a trick,
but that's how we got everybody's attention.
That how we got above the noise. 'Cause sometimes,
you can have a great idea, but you still gotta
get people to know about it.
>>Ted Hope: But my point was the pleasure
was that it was a trick. That people love
that in terms of like, that moment that they
guy had in Anchorage, Alaska, a place where
you don't get to go out and certain things
are still legal, [Frank Rose laughs] so you
have other things that help lead you to that
kind of WTF moment. [Susan Bonds laughs]
>>Frank Rose: Right.
>>Ted Hope: We've reached a point, I think,
in our muscle memory of how we receive stories.
My ten-year old looks at Dr. Who and says,
"Oh, I understand the code." [panel members
laugh heartily] And I'm like, "What?" It’s
like, "I understand the story code." He's
like--
>>Paul Woolmington: How old is he?
>>Ted Hope: Yeah, like, that was like, how
I understood OK, you don't watch whatever
the children series was. And you're going
to have to start watching Torchwood once you
get two digits? [Paul Woolmington laughs]
It's like, you're breaking it down too fast.
But that fact that we still do tell stories
as we did a hundred years ago in the movies,
in the beginning, middle, and an end.
We recognize it when we see the hand gun in
the first act. It will go off in the third.
And we understand that's way too programmed
and we no longer want that from that entertainment.
We need to have engineer the WTF moments when
someone says, "Oh my God. It's someone who's
insane who's directing this." How great is
that?
>>Frank Rose: Right.
>>Paul Woolmington: Chris?
>>Chris Di Cesare: I'm sorry, Frank.
>>Frank Rose: Yeah, I think that if I can
go back to Lost again, another thing that
I had in this discussion with Damon and Carleton
was that they said that when fans come up
to them and wanted to talk about the show,
they basically got two reactions.
And one was they wanted to be reassured that
the producers knew where the story was going.
That it was actually going to go somewhere.
And the other was that they wanted to have
some sense that they, the fans, could actually
influence the story. And as Damon and Carlton
said, these two impulses are actually kind
of contradictory except that they're not entirely
contradictory.
The conversation bore out essentially. What
came out was that because television is such
an iterative process, a TV series, unlike
a movie where obviously the whole thing is
made before anyone sees it. But with the television
shows, especially one that lasts over a period
of years, there is a chance for the audience
to provide feedback if the producers are listening.
And certainly in the case of Lost, Damon and
Carlton were listening. And the example they
gave me was these two low-lifes, Nikki and
Paulo, who appeared in I think it was the
middle of Season Three. And that was before
they had managed to set an end date for the
series.
So, the producers had no idea how long the
show was gonna have to go on and how long
they were gonna have to spin this out. And
so, they introduced these characters and the
audience viewers just went, "Wait a minute.
We've been watching this show for two and
a half years and suddenly two new survivors
show up?"
Number one. And number two, "We don't like
these people at all. They're slimy and get
them out of here."
>>Susan Bonds: Rejected.
>>Frank Rose: Right. So, the fans rejected,
the audience rejected the new characters.
And what Carlton said was they listened to
this. They heard this. And they said, "OK,
you want us to get rid of these people. All
right. We'll not only kill them, we'll fucking
bury them alive." And that's what they did
in the show.
[laughter]
>>Chris Di Cesare: It's funny. One thing around
that in terms of participation, like sometimes
you can let the people driving the experience
can listen too closely and that can screw
you up, too.
>>Frank: Right.
>>Chris Di Cesare: Like, the first ARG, The
Beast was this program that we did where you
end up like the vocal minority. Of course,
it's going to give you more feedback then
you'll ever wanna deal with. And then you
start chasing after the pleas that point zero
zero one percent of the audience and then
you end up alienating everyone else.
So, I think that's one of the biggest challenges
in this participatory way. As, how do you
balance with the audience, even the guy who
doesn't speak up? But they probably outnumber
the people that do.
>>Frank Rose: Right. Exactly. And another
example of this is Dickens, who of course
wrote all of his novels as serials. They came
out monthly. And he had barely finished writing
one series of chapters before he had to start
on the next one. And so, that was a very iterative
process as well.
And he listened very carefully to his readership.
He didn't always do what they wanted him to
do. In "The Old Curiosity Shop," when it became
apparent little Nell was not really going
to make it much longer, people went nuts.
And there were practically riots on the street.
There was a ship that landed in New York from
England. This was a time when information
traveled a little more slowly than it does
now. And it was met on the docks by a crowd
of people saying, "Is little Nell dead?"
[laughter]
And so, in that case, obviously, Dickens did
not listen to his readership. He knew what
would make a good story. And he knew that
as much as his readers said they didn’t
want little Nell to die, secretly they did.
[panel members chuckle] And, but there were
other stories where at times when the story
wasn't going as well, like "Martin Chuzzlewit"
for example, when he did listen very carefully
to the audience, to the readers.
And so, I think that's part of it. You have
to know when to listen and when not to.
>>Paul Woolmington: I have to weave marketing
in here a little bit because obviously it's
interesting. My observation is that there's
a dearth of good work coming out of the marketing
industry around, you know, liberating themselves
out of the way they've always done things.
Why do we think that is? Is it again back
to the same old adage that you've got the
same people with the same sort of muscle memory
producing the work? And what is it gonna take
to break out of that?
Is it gonna require just different types of
teams? And again, I know you've touched on
this a little bit, Susan, but you obviously
must work in a very creative environment but
with really interesting multidisciplined--.
And I was also taken with what Chris was saying
was 'cause also this level and the attention
to detail and the sort of detail that you
need to go through is unlike the sort of detail
that we tend to look at when you're producing
marketing campaigns.
And so, it's this different way of actually
building this whole ecosystem of, and also
having that flexibility to respond to things
and not quite knowing where you're gonna need
to go. But you've got the people and the resources,
or you're gonna jump on it, which again, is
simply marketeers and more traditional storytellers
often aren't flexible. So, that's quite a
long question, but it was weave in the whole
marketing thing.
>>Susan Bonds: Well, coincidentally, where
we started was how can we do something to
get the attention of the marketing adverse?
We now have the ability to program our lives.
When we were first start talking about content
to come out on the web in the '90s, we were
like, "Oh, we'll just make programs and put
them online and at 8 o'clock on Tuesday people
will show up." Well, people don't show up
because the internet is theirs, right?
And you can do whatever you want with it.
Your phone is yours. Your tablet. It's like,
I can program my life. I can TiVo. I can whatever.
So, I think that if you look at the discontinuity
or the sea change that's happened, I think
taking too long to embrace it is going to
be fatal, right?
So, one thing is to recognize that the sea
has changed. So that's number one. And then
number two is like, I think what we have seen
with the marriage of entertainment and marketing
is that if you can take what is the great
attributes of the core property and you can
extend that out.
And it's now possible to do. There's no better
marketing in the world. It's like, "Let's
let people experience what your world or story
is." And that requires a tremendous different
type of set-up than a traditional ad agency.
>>Paul Woolmington: Well, and it's something
we're working on at Naked actually. It's I
think psychology as long since understood
since Freud was out and cognitive behavioral
psychology is in. And yet, a lot of marketing
still follows this theory of Freud theory,
which is keep asking the question "why?" and
we're gonna reflect as opposed to--.
And I think what it's doing and essentially
it's one of the marketing golden rules was
AIDA, Awareness drives Interest drives Desire
drives Action. But actually, the whole thing
has now been flipped on its head. And if you
follow cognitive behavioral strategy or psychology
and you say, "It's all about actions.
It's all about these actions which actually
drive interest, desire, and then probably
awareness." In that fashion. So, I think that's
also having a huge impact on the way in which--.
And of course the digital age is social media
or digital is the perfect place for action,
but it's how do we then take that action into
the traditional media and things like that?
>>Ted Hope: I think what really starts to
change is where we really start to place the
value on the communities that we create around
our stories. You know, much in the way Chris
was saying with Bees and everything. People
wanted to hear the stories other people told.
That's what kept bringing them back was the
social component. And when we do that, we
get a little bit more distance from being
on-point, on-message. I have, a couple times,
been able to get the marketing departments
in the film industry it's a real problem because
no one wants to give up any piece of their
budget.
On "Adventureland," a movie I did a couple
years back, we were able to get the marketing
department of Miramax to give us money to
shoot additional content. We were in an amusement
park. We had young actors who were booked
for the run of the show.
And I got like two funnier guy directors to
come aboard and just well, invent stuff. And
we made training videos for the amusement
park from the period.
>>Paul Woolmington: Brilliant.
>>Ted Hope: And we made a documentary. One
of the characters ran around hitting everyone
in the balls and we did an anthropological
look at the different ways it's done and all
of that. And we deliver this stuff that was
very funny.
[laughter]
Miramax looked at it and they said, "This
is not on-message. This is not on-point. We
don't know what to do." And I think that--
[laughter]
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah.
>>Ted Hope: as we start to recognize the community,
we also recognize I'm not on-message all the
time. I don't need it. I still like to go
back to that world. I relate to that character,
not the one that was punching in the balls.
The other, the Jesse Eisenberg one I related
more to. But, and it gives us that reason.
If we put the value, if we say, "We built
this huge two and a half million people for
Batman, we're not gonna let them go. We're
gonna keep them there and feed them more things."
>>Susan Bonds: And actually, it was actually
11 million people who participated in The
Dark Knight because people wanna live in Gotham
City. And there were six decades of dreaming
about it.
But I do think what you're saying is incredibly
important, which is the internet has provided
us a tool to be very targeted. So like, I
watched Lost because I wanted Jack and Kate
to get together, obviously.
[laughter]
Which I was able to clearly influence the
writers to make happen. But I mean, like other
people are watching for completely different
reasons. And so, I think it gives you the
ability to say, "OK, well you're watching
for this reason, you for that one." We can
give content to you that's not a trillion
dollars and we can make you feel like, "Oh,
yeah. They're validating why I think this
material is cool. This world is cool."
>>Paul Woolmington: So, I'm gonna ask the
panel one more question and then you guys
please think of some really smart questions
'cause I'll then open it. Janine , are we
good on time?
>>Janine: Yeah.
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah, great. I just wanted
to ask each of you, who's inspiring you at
the moment? Or, what's inspiring you? Maybe
not just who, but what's inspiring you in
what you're doing and how you're thinking
about new things, new books to write, Frank,
or work you're doing at Google, Chris.
And I'd just love to--. Maybe I'll start with
Frank 'cause you've got a furtive mind and
you're interviewing people. Is it who or is
it what?
>>Frank Rose: Sure. I mean, this is sort of
odd, but I find that there's a whole generation
for which the stuff that we're talking about
and trying to sort out just comes entirely
naturally. And a few weeks ago, I had brunch
with this guy who was down from Boston who
had just graduated from BU.
His name is Nate Goldman. And he had done
a, he had spent two years as an undergrad,
putting together for no credit or anything
this War of the Worlds type zombie experience
[panel members chuckle]that took place over
a variety of different media. Primarily, his
college radio station.
Also he got people to dress up in the streets
and all kinds of stuff. And to him, this was
just utterly natural. This was just how you
would do something like that. He did it without
any particular resources, except for access
to the radio station. He had never heard of
transmedia or Henry Jenkins or my book or
anything until after it was over.
[more chuckling]
And I thought that was brilliant.
[laughter]
I thought this is, in a way, in my wildest
dreams I'm John the Baptist.
[laughter]
>>Paul Woolmington: Chris.
>>Chris Di Cesare: One thing, I guess who
I'm really impressed by. One thing on YouTube
that I'm like, amazed by is that where the
top partners on YouTube, these guys who create
these web series are amazing to me because
not only do they have to create the content,
they have to market the content.
They have to basically become this A-B-C,
but they're sitting in their bedroom creating
all this. [Paul Woolmington chuckles] And
some of them now are making big bucks. I mean,
so just this and it's the same thing, they
probably have no idea when they started that
that was they were gonna become a network
unto themselves.
But people now that know that they not only
create the content, but how to foster and
grow a community, I'm just amazed by.
>>Paul Woolmington: Susan.
>>Susan Bonds: So, just to echo what these
guys are saying, I think for me, what is inspiring
to me is actually seeing people go after these
sacred silos and saying, "Well, I'm not going
to do it like that. I'm going to do it differently."
And I mean, I look at, I think they do quality
programming at HBO, but they're also thinking
about what is it people really want.
And they're launching things that give people
access to content that is counterintuitive.
You're like, "Well, if we give them access
to next week's episode this week, then who's
gonna come back and watch it next week?" But
in fact, they're just feeding the frenzy because
people feel like, "Oh. We are somehow participating
in all this quality entertainment that's coming
out."
But I think the thing I'm really looking for
is what we're saying, which is someone who
is not in any way, no one foot, toe, finger,
whatever, stuck to the notion of traditional
media models. They're just like, 'Well, we're
just gonna do it like this." And then everyone's
gonna look and go, "Oh yeah. We were stuck
over here so we couldn't see that, but now
that we see it, we can all go for that."
>>Ted Hope: There's a lot of great work that's
being done out there that inspires me on a
daily basis. The thing that I struggle with
most and what I'm always looking for is the
folks who are willing to slow down to try
to tell a big story that in the independent
world, people write this script and then they
think they can make a movie right away.
I've been working for about three years with
a filmmaker named Lance Wiler, who is in some
ways the most famous filmmaker that nobody
knows. But we've been doing a transmedia build,
working a long time on the script to make
sure that the story element of it truly holds
up and has enough openings in it at the same
time that it can last for a much bigger world.
And along the way, he's been willing to do
what he calls a lot of "story R&D," things
that he, whether they're events or installations
or films or apps. Putting things out into
the community, letting people play with it.
Some of this, Frank touches in his book, emergent
storytelling, emergent game play, really not
needing to succeed in making a masterwork
of art at an early stage, but willing to let,
let's see how people play with it and try
to adapt that.
But really the part that for all of this tons
of visionary whatever he did at age 15, it
didn't come my way in pill form. I really
wish that I had gotten hold of, but the thing
that's really most impressive to me is the
willingness to, like, I don't have to produce
it overnight. I don't need to be proclaimed
a genius.
I don't need to win the Sundance Film Festival
and get picked up. I can actually try to manage
something. I'm gonna engage a lot of people
and I'm gonna depend on the crowd for us to
try to get it right. That to me is very inspiring.
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah. No, that's great.
My only comment would be to celebrate the
brilliant misfits that sort of--. That's what
we try and say at Naked is we're always trying
to hire the brilliant misfits. Clearly, everyone
wants brilliant people, but--
>>Ted Hope: Good listing.
[laughter]
>>Paul Woolmington: Yeah, but anyway. That's
a nice segue because I know that there's,
I think, some friends of Google in the audience
and certainly I think there's a number of
people from, I think, brilliant misfits in
the audience 'cause I've had the pleasure
of working with the Creative Lab and some
of the amazing people are working there.
So, I'd love to throw it open to the audience
to obviously ask anyone any questions. I think
there are microphones here, or we're a relatively
small audience, so just shout your question
out if you've got any. Please.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: I was talking
that I work with Lance and I've worked with
him on a couple of projects and he definitely
gives up authorship and he starts small, which
is fantastic.
So, he's always tweaking things as he's going
through a process. I work for OgilvyEntertainment
on trying to harness social media and gaming
for social change. And a wall I come up against
daily is that social change isn't really exciting
to audiences at their core.
What's exciting to people is conflict. But
obviously, I'm working with big brands and
brands don't want to be associated with conflict.
So, what do you think about that?
>>Susan Bonds: Well, I think that's--. I mean,
obviously lots of people are always coming
to us saying, "How can we use this for good?"
And going back to where we were able to see
in Year Zero, was you can't tell people what
to care about, but you can set up a construct
through which they see the world through different
eyes.
But you're really at a conflict yourself,
because you just pointed it out. 'Cause great
storytelling has conflict. So, you can't really
put someone else in someone else's shoes unless
you create that drama. So, I mean, I believe
in that entertainment, like we've seen it.
There's a million examples we can point to,
films that made us think differently about
the world or an issue or a situation. So,
I think that this media is as well. You have
to stick true to good quality storytelling.
You have to put people in the world in the
situation in the story.
And you can't just expect them because it's
for good. You can't tell them what to care
about. We can't tell you people what to care
about either. You know what I'm saying? It's
like, "No, we're just gonna think for ourselves."
So what you can do is bring them into a world
of story where they experience it personally
and it changes the way they see the world.
That's my two cents.
>>Paul Woolmington: Question in the back.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: [ inaudible; off
the microphone ] just to go back to what he
was talking about this idea of building stories
to go through the times, starting small and
taking longer to create, which obviously sounds
fantastic.
But who's investing in those types of projects?
Who has this sort of vision to be able to
back those types of eyes and are allowed to
get on with their craft but over like a two,
three, or even perhaps a four year period?
>>Ted Hope: Yeah, I wish I knew that answer.
[laughter]
>>Susan Bonds: Did you get their telephone
number?
>>Ted Hope: It's hard. Particularly in the
tech world, there's always ways to raise funds
for experiment and innovation. And it's a
lot harder in the content business for that.
I think that part of the problem we're also
relying on a financial model that is, again,
based on generally the feature film dominance
or ad-based television.
So, how do we start to move to something else?
'Cause certainly if I can bring a community
together that stays together over a long period
of time and all I'm doing is selling them
a ticket, or a download, to a movie, I'm not
a very good businessperson. If I can find
people's liked interests I should be able
to drive a fair amount of different forms
of commerce through that community.
I think that part of the problem is we're
probably still all looking at old revenue
models for it as opposed to something that's
more of a new revenue model. If we're bringing
people together and they're responding to
the things that we like, they're revealing
a great deal of data that's useful to a lot
of different people, too.
>>Paul Woolmington: Chris.
>>Susan Bonds: I actually think, too, that
this is an opportunity because you don't have
to open a movie on opening weekend to get
your world out there. You can do things on
much smaller platforms and start building
an audience.
And that is a huge way in for a lot of people
that didn't have a way in before. So, I think
it's a big opportunity.
>>Ted Hope: I mean, if you look at Marvel
and DC, basically comics were a great inexpensive
way for character generation and testing.
Had they had the business plans that they
would become the big entertainment entities
that they are today, I don't know if anyone
would've believed them.
Like, "This is what we're going to do, is
publish on cheap pulp paper for 40 years and
then we're going to make a hundred million
dollar celluloid things."
[laughter]
>>Paul Woolmington: Stan Lee, yeah. An interesting
observation I think is that--and I hate to
plug another book--but there's a book by a
friend called Peter Sims and it's "Small Bets."
And have a read of it. And I think it's just
interesting him talking a lot about small
bets.
We have this tendency in Hollywood and in
marketing and what's the big idea, you know?
Everyone's looking for this big idea. And
actually, the greatest successes of today
were these iterative successes where they
place small bets and they made mistakes and
learnt by their mistakes.
And that's the theory behind the book and
it's just this notion of how you experiment.
You were talking a little bit about the loosening
yourself up into that experimentation mode,
but I think we're gonna see so many more amazing
business plans come out of small bets and
being able to lose, but lose small but learn
from it.
I think that's interesting.
>>Chris Di Cesare: Yeah, just to add on that,
I just think that that's the beauty of the
web in the fact that costs are coming down.
And I think it's where people can produce
their own short stories or films and tell
their own stories in a way that you could
never--.
The barriers of entry are just so different.
And if you can find an audience then it goes
from there. So, it's about if you get the
momentum behind you, I think they sky's the
limit.
>>Paul Woolmington: Well, are there any other
burning questions? Any other burning questions?
Yes.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: I was wondering
what your views are on the anonymity of authorship
on the internet. And for instance, there's
recently the guy that was supposedly like
a lesbian somewhere and he was actually some
married guy in Sweden and how we're being
tricked into things, that what we should do
about that and how we can get around the deficiency?
>>Paul Woolmington: Anyone want to take that?
Frank?
[laughter]
>>Frank Rose: I would just like to point out
that on the internet, everybody knows you're
a dog.
[laughter]
As with the purported lesbian who, it comes
out soon enough. I don't know. I think that's
another example of the kind of blur that I
was talking about. It's obviously impossible
to make sure that everybody is exactly who
they say they are.
And I suppose in some way, that's part of
its charms.
>>Susan Bonds: Well, I definitely have an
answer for that in terms of creative content,
which is don't perpetrate a hoax because people
will find you out. And I think that what you
end up being and like what we've always tried
to do is provide a clever way to invite people
into the story that's buzz generating and
cool.
So then they go, "Oh, well I saw that and
I did that." But once people are like, trying
to debunk you, the internet has infinite resources.
They will figure it out and as in this case--
>>Chris Di Cesare: Yeah.
>>Susan Bonds: they'll figure it out. So,
don't start that way because you will get
figured. Like, did everyone see the movie
Catfish? I mean, like other than being also
sad, but I mean, it's also like you will get
found out.
So, don't throw down the gauntlet because
somebody will pick it up.
>>Ted Hope: Or program the hoax into it at
all times. Like, that’s the point that should
be exposed.
>>Paul Woolmington: The reveal.
>>Susan Bonds: I don't think you can program
the hoax into it the whole time, but that's
not in this day and time. Not since Google.
[laughter]
>>Ted Hope: No, but the fact that it's going
to be discovered is part of the--.
>>Paul Woolmington: Well, on that moment,
just as the discussion was just about to get
heated. Susan and Ted were about to--. Anyway,
I'd like to first and foremost, thank Frank.
Well, firstly, thank Google for hosting this
event. Mega thanks to Janine and the team
at Creative Labs and everyone for coming out
on a hot, steamy day to be in a nice, air-conditioned
lovely catered venue. I thank Frank, "The
Art of Immersion." I think everyone's got
a free copy of the book.
Amazing book. I've read it twice now and I'm
giving it away to all my friends and I think
it's gonna run and run. Thanks Frank, Chris,
Susan, and Ted for being great panelists and
for just stimulating the debate. Thank you
everyone.
[applause]